.
WE ARE SUPPOSED TO HAVE
TRADITIONAL OPENING, SET UP THE
GAME, OTHER THINGS HAVE TO BE
TENDED TO.
ON BEHALF OF TURNER SPORTS, YOU
MEANT SO MUCH TO THE GAME OF
BASKETBALL, AND FOR BASKETBALL
FANS ALL AROUND, WE WANT TO GIFT
YOU THIS.
>> HERE WE GO.
>> FOR YOU, NO, SERIOUS, LARRY
O'BRIEN TROPHY FOR YOU, MARV.
THANK YOU FOR BLESSING US WITH
YOUR GIFT, YOUR GIFT, YOUR
VOICE.
>> ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
WOW.
>> I'M MOVING THIS IN THE
MIDDLE.
THIS IS FOR YOU, MY FRIEND.
BLOCKING YOUR HEAD.
THEY HAVE TO SEE THE REACTION.
THIS IS FOR YOU, MY FRIEND.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO SAY.
IS THIS THE LARRY O'BRIEN
TROPHY?
>> IT IS.
WHICH IS YOURS.
>> HOW AM I GOING TO TAKE IT
HOME.
>> ON THE PLANE!
>> NO.
>> BY THE WAY, I DROVE DOWN TO
MJ'S HOUSE IN CHICAGO, GOT ONE
OF THESE.
>> WILL HE KNOW IT IS MISSING?
>> HE HAS SIX OF THEM, DOESN